der heutigen sitzung geht es um das
thema moralische motivation bei immanuel
kant wir hatten schon gesehen dass das
verhältnis von gefühl und affekt ein
sehr spannungsreiches verhältnis ist was
moralische motivation anbelangt ich nach
oben rechts ein link zu der sitzung
hinein wo wir die theorie moralische
motivation bei david hume diskutiert
haben der dazu eine ganz klare
auffassung vertrat nämlich dass die
vernunft uns nicht motivieren kann im
manischen hinsichten sondern dass das
nur die effekte können dass die vernunft
nur eines klar wenn der effekt ist ganz
anders sieht es jetzt mit immanuel kants
theorie der moralischen motivation aus
am bewährten einen besonderen fokus
legen auf das moralische gefühle achten
dass kein gewöhnliches gefühl dass sein
wie kann sagt ein vernunft gewirkt das
gefühl als ein vernünftiges gefühl und
lassen es nach kant das einzige was für
moralische motivation ist also genau die
gegenthese von david hume ja ich gehe
jetzt mal ein bisschen auf ein paar
zitate ein hier ist immer anerkannt
abgebildet dass es ein recht
authentisches porträt und wir lesen
jetzt ein paar auszüge aus der kritik
der praktischen vernunft seine moral
philosophischen hauptwerk aus dem jahr
1788 ein paar leitfragen im dezember
direkt nach kant die vernunft genauer
gesagt die praktische fünf das gefühl
der achtung wie genau vermag die
vernunft die praktische unseren willens
saarland und zu motivieren das sind die
fragen die wir uns heute stellen wollen
die theorie moralische motivation ist
bei kann vor allem im dritten hauptstück
seine kritik der box zu vernunft
enthalten die den tier geprägt von den
triebfedern der rein praktischen
vernunft das ist das dritte hauptstück
kant gleich zu beginn das wesentlichen
wesentliche alles sittlichen wert ist
dass das das moralische gesetz
unmittelbar den willen bestimme es geht
nicht darum dass haben sich etwas
zwischen das sittengesetz und uns den
willen stellt und dann zu einer handlung
führt sagen das sittengesetz muss
unmittelbar uns empfehlen bestimmen kann
unterscheidet sie ja noch sehr treffen
zwischen die endlosen legalität und der
moralität eine handlung was es damit
genau auf sich hat das werden wir gleich
sehen ihn kommt es darauf an dass uns
behandlung nicht legal sind die
reduzierten gesetzes ohne moralisch kann
zeigt in einem anderen zitat das die
triebfeder sohn spricht er spricht von
dem moralischen triebfeder das ist
natürlich eine sehr
mechanische metapher wenn es um
moralische motivation geht aber auch
motivation hat ja was und beweggrund wir
sind ja immer im bereich der metaphorik
diese triebfeder die moralischen
motivation gewährleistet ist die kann
sagt der subjektive stimmungs grund des
willens und der muss damit es moralisch
wird nimmt der objektiv zugleich seien
hier sieht man also dass es kann bei der
moralischen motivation nicht darum geht
das sagen was uns alles motivieren
können sondern was uns moralisch
motivieren soll das heißt es geht nicht
darum dass wir nur die buchstaben des
hippen gesetzesgemäß handeln sondern wie
kann sagt dem geist des selben der geist
begriff ist natürlich auch ein hoch
problematischen begriff ich mache auch
oben rechts und links einem seminar wo
ich dieses thema behandelt hatte auch
eine tagung hatte ich zu diesem sehr
problematischen philosophisch begriff
des geistes organisiert was meint dass
jetzt der buchstabe des gesetzes meint
dass wir zum beispiel handeln nur aus
furcht vor strafe also wir handeln zwar
gemäß dem sie dem gesetz aber der grund
warum danach handeln der liegt nicht
selbst sittengesetz seiner wertschätzung
seine akzeptanz seiner
befürwortung sondern in einem möglichen
angst vor strafe wenn wir eben ertappt
werden das ist nur die legalität einer
handlung der geist hingegen bedeutet
dass wir wirklich den inneren sinn
dieses gesetzes einsehen gut für gut
heißen und eben auch danach handeln und
das der handlungs grund selbst im
sittengesetz in seinem normativität
begründet liegt
also es geht darum dass wir wenn wir
moralisch handeln unsere motivation
nicht
durch sinnliche antriebe bekannt sagt
bewegt werden das kann lust und zeit
sind individuelle vorlieben die
betreffen uns als individuum das darf
nicht der hauptkonkurrent sein es sagen
wir müssen sie abweisend diesen
individuellen neigungen so dass nur das
sittengesetz der bestimmung skript
unseres willens zur handlung ist
das ist jetzt aber nur die negative
seite moralischen motivation das
bedeutet moralische motivation ist immer
unabhängig vom individuellen neigungen
zu
vollziehen er kann spricht auch an einer
stelle das tugend moralische gesinnung
im kampf ist also dass wir gegen die
neigungen wirklich kämpfen müssen gegen
die gefühle das ist natürlich die
extreme gegenthese zu revidieren der
sagte neigungen effekte und vernunft die
können gar nicht mit dem land bekämpfen
weil sie auf einer ganz anderen ebene
liegen nach kant können sie tatsächlich
miteinander in konflikt geraten und das
ist gerade auch die tugend werden sich
die vernunft die praktische im kampf
bekannt sagt mit den individuellen
neigungen durchsetzt
jetzt bringt kann hier noch ein paar
charakterisierungen dieser individuellen
motivation die gerade überwunden werden
soll
kant nennen sie selbst sucht selbst
liebe bringt das malz begriff der
eigenliebe und vor allem auf den begriff
des eigenen denkens es sind also
subjektive einstellungen die dem gebot
den inhalt geistes sitten gesetzes
zuwider sind und kann sagt dass in dem
unsere individuellen neigungen durch das
sittengesetz in dem die eingeschränkt
werden entsteht ein phänomen das schmerz
genannt werden kann wir fühlen uns als
empirische wesen gedemütigt wenn wir die
objektive geld des vierten gesetzes
einsehen das ist aber nicht die ganze
geschichte der moralischen motivation
sondern es gibt auch noch eine positive
seite auf die wir gleich noch näher
eingehen also der eigenen dunkel sagt
kant der wird durch die reine praktische
vernunft
niedergeschlagen und
zwar sind
dieses was der eigentliche darstellt
ansprüche der selbst schätzen die vor
der übereinstimmung mit dem sittlichen
gesetze vorher gehen also dass die
auffassung dass wir nicht an das gesetz
gebunden sind und selbst
willkürlich bestimmen dürfen was gut und
was böse ist als der eigene dunkle die
übertriebene
ja individualität gegenüber der
objektiven universalität des gesetzes
und diese eigenen genuss nach cannes für
moralische motivation niedergeschlagen
werden also wirklich im kampf besiegt
werden durch die vernunft
jetzt ist es aber so dass wir einerseits
durch diese niederschlagung des
eigentümers schmerzempfinden nämlich als
empirisches individuelles wesen war ja
unsere individuellen neigungen hier
abgewiesen werden durch die objektivität
der moral auf der anderen seite dann
aber unter einem anderen gesichtspunkt
nämlich dann wenn wir uns als fünfte
gewesen betrachten die nicht nur durch
triebe und neigung
definiert sind
wir etwas positives dadurch entdecken
also wir fühlen uns wie kann sagt er
haben über uns für individuelle
neigungen in dem wir uns als vernünftige
wiesen erkennen und das erkannt ist ein
positives gefühl was ich dann hier kund
tut was nicht empirischen ursprungs ist
sondern was vernünftig ist ein up rio
risches gefühl ein moralisches gefühl
welches durch an intellektuellen grundes
das sittengesetz gewirkt wird und das
ist noch kein wort das einzige das wir
völlig apriori unabhängig vom verfahren
erkennen sogar das ist eine sehr starke
these weil wir es hier mit einer
akribischen form fand seligkeit zu tun
haben die eigentlich gar nicht einen
platz hat im kampfsystem
spricht auch noch davon dass wir durch
das sittengesetz daneben gedemütigt
werden insofern wir uns eben als
eingeschränkt empfinden wenn es um
unsere eigentümer geht
kann sagt dann noch weiter dass die 48
gesetz die einzige und zugleich
bezweifelte moralische triebfeder ist es
gibt noch andere mögliche kandidaten
macht kann es im moralischen station zum
beispiel das mitleid und willi bekannt
sagt aber die haben immer noch zu viel
individuelle neigungen in sich und sind
nicht ganz dem geiste des gesetzes war
strukturiert
das ist also diese these und jetzt
spricht er hier noch mal von dieser
erhabenheit die dadurch entsteht dass
wir auf der sinnlichen seite gibt die
benötigt werden durch die erkenntnisse
sitten gesetzes auf die intellektuellen
seite aber eben eher haben werden weil
wir eben durch die verbindung der
hindernisse der empirischen neigungen
wenn die verhindert werden dann
entspricht das auf der anderen seite
einer beförderung desjenigen was eben
gehindert wird und behinderte die auf
eine praktische 5 in ihrer objektivität
und moralität der eben nach kant
gegensatz zur individuellen bergen
entgegen stehen wenn die neigung
weggeschafft werden dann ist die
verminderung der hindernisse eine
zumindest vermittelte beförderung der
ursprünglichen tätigkeit ja jetzt sagt
er das bewusstsein einer fein
unterwerfung des wissens unter das
sittengesetz mit einem unvermeidlichen
zwangen der alle neigungen steigen titel
aber nur durch eigene von unbekannten
punkten ist nun als gesetz wir fühlen
uns deswegen im grunde nicht gedemütigt
durch das gesetz weil wir erkennen dass
der kondensierten gesetzes in uns selbst
wir sind also darin nicht kette um wohn
bestimmt durch eine fremde macht sondern
wir sind autonom bestimmt im
eigentlichen sinne weil wir uns durch
unsere praktischen gesetz selbst geben
und zwar auf eine weise die eben unsere
individuellen neigungen einschränkt und
dann im vermittelter weise ein gefühl
der erhabenheit der moralischen dem
nichts bewirkt
ja dann sagt er hier noch es gibt eben
jetzt moralische schwärmerei
auffassungen die aber nur zur steigerung
des eigentümers fühlen führen wenn wir
eben an denken können dass
das joch des gesetzes dass das eben zu
stark wäre und man ist abmildern müsste
er bringt hier ebenso ein paar beispiele
wie man ist eben noch
mindern könnte zum beispiel durch
sympathie hre fiel auch die also formen
des mitleids der liebe das erkannt
bringt aber nur eine windige über
fliegende fantastische denkungsart
hervor die sich mit einer freiwilligen
gut artigkeit
fahrt und die eben dann den eindruck
erweckt dass man nicht sich dieser
strenge des gesetzes
unterwerfen müsste und das kritisiert
eben kant sehr scharfe kante hat
moralisch motivation immer auch eine
negative demütigende seite die eben
unsere empirische seitens wenn die
qualität betrifft friedrich schiller hat
hier dagegen argumentiert angesagt
sicherlich ist moralische motivation
erzählte achtung eine sehr würdevolle
angelegenheit hat dass die würde genannt
hat dem aber noch den begriff der
moralischen schönheit wird der anmutet
gegendarstellung gesagt wirkliche
moralische motivation die wirklichen
höchstens eine moralisch ist ist immer
auch schöne moralisch motivation die
eben nicht diese demütigung seite an
sich hat sich eine harmonie im einklang
mit unserer tierischen natur sich
vollzieht ja das war so weit war über
kants theorie des moralischen gefühls zu
achtung vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten sitzung